GOALIE IN JUST ABOUT PINCHING I.
HE'S ROLLING SIX GAME BACKINORSS
AND IT ACROSS TO HIS
SCORELESS AND SAN JOSE WITH 35
SECONDS LEFT IN MIDDLE
AND BARABANOV CUTS IN FRONT AND.
BUT IF YOU WATCH BARABANOV RIGHT
NEAR THE END.
HE'S JUST GOING TOLUCIC CELEBRA.
NO SIGNAL YET.
HILL DOWN.
THE R
THERE'S CERTAINLY A BUNCH OF
STICKS AND BODIES INT BE
JOHN MCCLAIN AND THE SHARKS --
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
ACTING HEAD COACH JOHN MCCLAIN
>> MIDWAY THROUGH THE CALGARY
POWER PLAY.
RASMUS ANDERSSON BACK TO IT.
NOW MANGIAPANE CARRIES THR
[ ♪ ]
LEWIS IN TO FACE OFF AGAINST
EBOUND OF DUBE AND
TKACHUK.
HILL IS ABLE TO HANG ON.
>> WITH TWO SEC BY YOU.
>> HERE IS JOHNNY GAUDREAU WITH
A PASSY HANGS ON.
12:18 TO
RASMUS ANDERSSON GOOD PLAY AT PE
BLUE LINE.
KNOCKING THE PUCK OUT OF THETO .
DOWN LOW FOR BALCERS.
FINDS HERTL.
HANIFIN.
BACKLUND.
LOOKS IN FRONT.
OFF THE A ROADE SHOOTERS WITH
>> BALCERS GOT A GOOD CHANCE.
>> SURE DID.
REBOUND. CREASE.
THE SHARKS ARE ON THE LOOSE
PUCK.
BARABANOV WHO HAS THE GOAL GETS.
>> GOES OFF
TANEV PRESSURE.
TUSH OVER.
MERKLEY TURNS AND ALIVE.
PITLICK.
PUCK BOUNCES BACK TOE.
RACING OFF IT IS HERTL.
GETS THERE TO TAKE OFF THE ICING
CALL AND THINK